[Music]
vivanco Monica sees on lookin for the
nickel in vivo shall we say Pascal econ
gonna oversee the locks on kotoba their
work of course large scale massacres
which allows we cannot quantify in any
measure stupid statue and it's a
reminder of the country really wasn't
built with you in mind first of all you
have to admit yourself that you part of
the problem
[Music]
the sign Contin Airpark in Brussels a
statement of grandeur dreamt up by king
leopold ii and crowned with his double-l
crest he paid for this with money taken
from Congo his own personal African
colony Leopold became fantastically rich
the Congolese were forced into labor
mutilated and killed in vast numbers
jean-claude illunga was born in Congo
but has made his life in Belgium sixty
years after it won independence he
believed Congo is still hobbled by its
colonial past
Sabo bitmoji ont constable el polvo
le Fay Calipari's Seco in a Jamaican
Bell cheeky NoHo connoisseurs Dolapo
Congo partisan le Calcutta Malone ed de
la parte de la belgique de la belgique
dunno pyrokinetic you see Audrey on a
sabbatical or magic
Sylvie ownership cetera says on the jig
just a glass oh ho ho
what hurts many is that Leopold still
crops up everywhere the tram stop cafe
street names and statues there is little
sign of his memory then shunned despite
the extraordinary brutality that Belgium
delivered upon Congo
this monument isn't even a hundred years
old but it fills archaic
and insight into Belgian colonial
attitudes there it talks about the black
race then there's a quote from leopold
ii saying that what he did was in the
interest of civilization and for the
good of belgium and on this central
portion you can see that the Congolese
are represented as grateful and
vulnerable their Belgium rulers are
seen as benevolent or in the case of the
soldiers are strong and resolute but
there is a sign that the modern world is
beginning to intrude Belgian colonial
rule was often about subjugation and
terrible brutality look at this photo
the man is staring at the severed hand
and foot of his child cut off because he
wasn't working hard enough
she was then killed along with the man's
wife in later years
Belgium tried to present itself as a
more benevolent ruler but independence
for Congo exposed a hollowed-out shell a
massive country with no infrastructure
doomed to fail sure enough war and
economic collapse followed in the
decades after independence 80% of the
Congolese population now live in extreme
poverty
Otunga is the heart of the Congolese
community in Brussels Alena runs a
community center here
she says colonial attitudes still
permeate Belgian society putting on on
Belgian people was like yeah but Congo
needs civilization they're bad they the
way that they do things over there it's
not okay they're not smart enough and
did and that and that's the way that a
lot of people Belgian people intend to
see Africans as well like you have those
stereotypes that are not broken yet and
she's not alone in that sentiment there
are many here who believe they are
treated as second-class citizens pushed
aside by the ripples of a colonial past
one thing about racism is it makes you
feel really quite lonely I'm not the
only one who feels the rage who feels
the loneliness who walks by by a stupid
statue and and it's a reminder of the
country really wasn't build with you in
mind and you'll have to work twice as
hard or or much harder than than other
people to find your place in it in the
Brussels suburb sits the museum that
Leopold paid to have built the grounds
here once held a human Zoo where
Congolese villagers were put on show
inside there are grotesque vestiges of
the past but one of the Belgians leading
historians told me this all needs to be
kept understood and remembered it would
be very dangerous to erase and to
destroy every sign every remnant every
impact of Leopold or of colonialism in
the Belgian society because Belgian
society would be in certain sense and
music there would be a sort of amnesia
towards the colonial past the decades
the museum barely changed but now it's
been redesigned the curator says it now
confronts uncomfortable reality and the
Belgium society should follow suit we
need to have much stronger diversity
policies that we have today and the day
we do the way we do research we have to
rethink a lot of that so decolonization
is a process which takes time we've
taken the first steps but there still
long way to go in the museum's grounds
Leopold statue has been defaced again
this nation is gradually coming to terms
with its colonial past but it is a slow
and awkward process
Adam Parsons Sky News Brussels